monsieur bonsoir choisi personnellement
par ben laden et seul accusé par la
justice américaine pour complicité dans
les attentats du 11 septembre
zacarias moussaoui plaide coupable ce
français arrêté peu avant les attaques
contre les tours jumelles a reconnu
qu'il s'était entraîné à frapper la
maison blanche
cette détermination à reconnaître les
faits du évite un procès alors que
certains évoquent une santé mentale
fragile houssaoui risque la peine de
mort a lancé levant arandia mende dans
ce 4 4 aux vitres fumées
zacarias moussaoui arrive au tribunal
d'alexandria près de washington s'était
dit hier 15 heures deux jours plus tôt
il avait fait venir la présidente de la
cour dans sa prison j'ai l'intention de
plaider coupable lui avait-il dit
va-t-il maintenant réitéré ses aveux
dans une audience publique
le franco-marocain seul inculpé dans les
attentats du 11-septembre a déjà avoué
dans le passé puis il s'était rétracté
mais là d'emblée il réaffirme sa
culpabilité et donne même des détails
c'est ben laden en personne qui m'a
demandé d'aller fracassé un avion sur la
maison blanche
mais c'était un autre complot que le 11
septembre où sa wii semble fier de se
dépeindre en héros du djihad
sélectionnés par le chef vous rendez
vous compte des conséquences de ce que
vous dites demande la magistrate
tout à fait répond moussaoui qui signe
immédiatement des aveux détaillés
ses avocats plaident contre la vie de
leurs clients les responsabilités ces
aveux n'ont aucune valeur distille pas
du tout tranché la juge moussawi est
intelligent et connaît la loi je le
déclare coupable
aussitôt le ministre de la justice
triomphe le fait que moussaoui et
participé à un complot terroriste n'est
plus mise en doute
et plus que jamais nous demandons la
peine de mort quant aux familles des
victimes du 11 septembre
elle voit déjà moussaoui sur une chaise
électrique anita lantigua quelle que
soit sa peine il l'aura mérité
est ce que nous demandons la peine de
mort absolument
dans les semaines ou les mois qui
viennent un jury populaire devrait être
constituée qui déterminera la peine
peine qui pourrait donc bien être la
mort les en dissociant ses aveux du 11
septembre
zacarias moussaoui espère sans doute
avoir enfoncé un coin dans la c
complexe le procédure judiciaire
américaine